what's going on guys so continuing in my
series of Star Wars reviews we now get
to a strange spot in Star Wars history
originally my next review was going to
be for Revenge of the Sith but I realize
if I'm doing this chronologically I
should probably talk about the Clone
Wars feature film then I realized
there's really not that much to talk
about there so why not do a combo review
the Clone Wars feature film the Clone
Wars television show and comb Wars the
2003 animation because that's the only
way that my OCD perfectionist
completionist mind I'll be satisfied now
unlike my reviews for episode 1 & 2 I'm
not going to do any spoilers in this
video because I know a lot of you
haven't actually seen the feature film
so I want to keep it as vague as
possible Star Wars the Clone Wars came
out in 2008 it was a theatrical feature
and a lot of people were very confused
by this because for a long time Lucas
had been talking about an animated Star
Wars television show all the way back to
doing press for Revenge of the Sith he
mentioned they were planning a CGI
animated Star Wars show we are going to
do a TV series it's been out in little
bits and pieces as the Clone Wars it'll
continue as the Clone Wars it's going to
be a 3d animated series about a half an
hour long it wasn't until he saw footage
from the first few episodes that he
decided he would like it to be a movie
this made it hard on the creators
because they didn't really have a budget
for a feature film this movie is
actually four episodes that were planned
for the show meshed into one thing to
make it a feature-length runtime it's a
really bad idea but Lucas for some
reason thought it would be a good one as
usual his ideas just aren't the greatest
any more Lucas what are you doing man
nevertheless this movie follows Anakin
and obi-wan smack dab in the middle of
the Clone Wars and Anakin has suddenly
taken on an apprentice called ahsoka
so Anakin's trying to train this young
girl obi-wan is trying to keep Anakin on
somewhat of a leash and ahsoka is
learning a lot about the force now this
is circling around a very convoluted
plot to get a little baby Hutt lit back
to its Hutt family this movie is a bit
of an oddity because when you watch it
you can tell something about this wasn't
made for theatres this was made for
television and now they're trying to
make it into
thing for theaters so people who went
and saw this movie largely viewed it as
a gigantic promotional commercial for
the upcoming TV show and in some ways it
was let's face it the movie really is
just a series of long emotionless action
scenes that's really all this movie is
it goes from a few battles to a few more
battles and it's nothing but this very
wooden mechanical mannequin like acting
it's really terrible actually because
you can tell that Dave Filoni the
director was just really getting his
footing here and the animators were more
than likely struggling with these
strange budgetary concerns and demands
from George Lucas to make it into a
feature when they were really just
planning for a television show the whole
time the characters faces their mouths
are moving in sync with dialogue but
their eyes and the position of their
face doesn't reflect even half of the
emotion that Pixar or DreamWorks is able
to accomplish with their animated films
but you can really tell it's mainly
because they weren't setting out to make
a movie I mean imagine that you're
sitting down you're planning for months
and months and even really a couple
years the first few episodes of a
television show and then the big guy who
signs all the checks comes in and says
yeah I want to make it a movie let's
make it a movie and you're like uh we we
we don't have the money for that man we
we don't ha ha I'm George Lucas you can
do whatever you want
and that's really the big issue here
with this movie it just wasn't made for
theaters but it was released in theaters
so let's push the movie aside and start
talking about the thank goodness much
better TV show the clone wars that
followed there are still some strange
things about this show and by far the
biggest one is that the airing of it was
not in chronological order why like
that's one of the dumbest things I've
ever heard why would you purposely err a
show out of order do you know how many
kids watch the Cartoon Network I mean
really do you know how many kids are
like why is this personal life here and
then dead in the next one and then back
to life in the next one it didn't make
any sense it was so confusing gratefully
Star Wars com released the official
chronological order in which you could
watch the show
so thank goodness for that because that
was a little strange I was like why are
all these thing and then as soon as that
happened I went back I watched it in
chronological order the first episode is
actually like in season 2 it's so weird
why would you die I can't believe I
can't fathom why anyone would do that
it'd be like releasing return the Jedi
first then later doing a new hope and
then maybe like in 2010 and we'll just
release Empire Strikes Back who cares I
don't get it it's such a weird choice
let's stop talking about that how's the
quality of the show compared to the
movie it's like leaps and bounds better
I mean the animation has improved the
animation is more emotionally resonant
the ship to ship battles look great the
CG is actually really good for a
television show and better than the
theatrical film the CGI in this show
still isn't really film worthy you know
it's not really theater worthy but it's
made for TV and at home on the small
screen it looks fantastic and the show
introduced quite a bit of really
interesting expanded universe storylines
that you can actually get really
invested in they brought back some
characters Darth Maul that were really
awesome to see because it was like Darth
Maul why would you kill Darth Maul he
was by far the best part of Phantom
Menace Clone Wars was like you know what
you're right let's try to figure out a
way to get that in there and they did
and I do recommend watching it in
chronological order because you can
actually follow the storylines better
the Clone Wars TV show had much better
animation although it is still wooden at
times the emotion was better conveyed
through the animation the dogfights were
great the lightsaber battles did come
off a bit robotic from time to time
there wasn't that physical weight or
gravity there with the way the bodies
were interacting it's hard to describe
if you watch the Clone Wars show I think
you know what I mean sometimes it really
does look a bit videogame esque it just
didn't really look like it had the
physics there you know and that's one of
the things about CG that's really
important to understand is how heavy or
how light something is that you're
animating and how to make that look as
realistic as possible and some of the
lightsaber battles don't really work
that well in my opinion but the entire
show and the movie I just mentioned are
both on Netflix you can google it right
now look at the chronological order and
watch it in that it'll be much better
trust me now let's talk about something
that is by far the most underrated Star
Wars thing ever no one talks about this
anymore it won
multiple Emmys it was directed by the
man who brought you Dexter's Laboratory
Powerpuff Girls and Samurai Jack and
it's done in the same style a Samurai
Jack
great cartoon if you've never seen it
that is simply Clone Wars this is by far
one of the best things that the prequel
saga ever gave us this is such a great
cartoon this came out before the Clone
Wars the CG show this is all hand-drawn
there's some digital animation included
and it was a micro series these are 15
minute episodes that are all combined to
sort of make a film they were released
on Cartoon Network
and then on the Internet simultaneously
and they were always released before
Cartoon Network's Friday lineup of
cartoons so you could kind of get in the
mood for it it was like one of the first
things you could see after you got home
from school it was so much fun and if
you loved Samurai Jack like I do what is
so great about the Clone Wars micro
series is the animation style some
people really hated it I loved it but
what's so good about this show is just
through directions storyboards and
images and perfect timing in regards to
editing it was very suspenseful and it
really explored Anakin's turned towards
the dark side actually really well
particularly in his lightsaber battle
with Ventress which is still my favorite
thing involving any Star Wars animation
ever the music and the timing of the
shots was just primal they really
captured Anakin's anger and rage when he
was in this lightsaber battle and it's
better than anything in the CG show in
my opinion I just I love it I think it's
so underrated I don't think enough
people saw this show you can watch the
entire show in about two hours so if you
have never seen the micro series Clone
Wars I strongly recommend it it has
excellent action really good hand-drawn
animation the focus is never really on
dialogue although there is some good
dialogue and humor throughout the show
it's always on visual storytelling
telling your story through these amazing
images and I would strongly recommend it
if you've never seen it it is by far my
favorite Clone Wars anything Star Wars
the Clone Wars the feature film gets a C
- Star Wars the Clone Wars CG show gets
a beep
US and Star Wars Clone Wars the micro
series gets an a so next month is going
to be my Revenge of the Sith review but
I had to get the Clone Wars stuff out of
the way because I realized if I didn't
do it now it was going to be like after
Return of the Jedi and that just
wouldn't make any sense you're talking
about the originals you're getting
excited for seven and all of a sudden
going to take you back to the Clone Wars
I had to do it now but I also have
something pretty cool to talk to you
guys about really quick also involving
Star Wars there's new trading card game
out right now called Star Wars digital
card trader it's an app you can download
they contacted me and were nice enough
to provide me with some details about
this and we're wondering if I could
perhaps just mention it to you guys
since this is a Star Wars review they
have all the nostalgic cards from the
70s and 80s from the original trilogy as
well as upcoming cards from Star Wars
Episode seven including Poe Dameron and
bb-8 the new Droid and we just talked
about the Clone Wars Clone Wars cards
are available as well and since it's all
digital you don't to horde up your
shells with tons of cards because trust
me I know a thing or two about hoarding
and running out of space so guys there
are links in the description below if
you want to learn more about this and
download the app for your phone thank
you to Tops for asking me to do this and
thank you to you guys for watching my
continuing string of Star Wars reviews
episode 3 is going to be next month I'm
really looking forward to talking about
that one with you guys I know that's a
bit of a divisive one a lot of people
love it some people hate it some people
are in the middle it's not like it's
very common there's a very strange
polarizing opinion of that movie and I'm
looking forward to talking about it with
you guys as always thank you so much for
watching and if you did see the Star
Wars Clone Wars feature film or the CG
show or the micro-budget animated series
I'd love to know your thoughts below
thanks again guys and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
you